たくみふくしゃちょーっていうやつがいるんですけど、
あいつはね、
心が異常に綺麗なんですよ
まぁそういうシンプルな奴こそ
シンプルなドッキリに弱いっていうことは
僕はもう知ってます。
なんで今日はですね
今日は何とですよ
しゃあ
やばい見えないか
今日はね、
たくみがね、きっと後々来るんで、
この巨大バケツにね
僕が入って
たくみが俺ん家に遊びに来た時に
この中で僕がこうずっと待機してて
携帯で「勝手に入っていいよ」って言って
彼が入ってくるじゃないすか？
彼は間違いなく思うわけですよ
「なんだこれ」
彼が迷いもなく「なんだろうこれ」と思ったところに
ばぁ～！って中から出て来るっていう・・・
まあ、いたってシンプルっすよ
シンプルですけど・・・
・・・
僕がちょっと入ってみたいだけ、っていうね・・・
僕やっぱり身体デカいんで
結構デカいんだよ、130ℓだから結構あるから
全然入れるとは思うけれども
普通には座れない
てことは、足を折り畳んで座るしかない
あぁ、ヤバ
嫌な予感がしてきた
おぉ、おぉ・・・
あっ！あぁ、つる！足つる！
あぁ・・・
意外といけそうだな
うぅああぁ
あぁーーーっ
ギリギリいけない
もっともっと奥に入れってことかな？
どうすればいい
うあぁーーーっ
うおぅ、うおぅ
最後の蓋が閉まらない！
あぁーっ！あと少しなのに、頭がまだはいんない
どうすればいい？
・・・ってんの？わからない！
（叫び声）
え？これ閉まってる？
わかんない
（叫び声）
え？これどう・・・
暑い！暑いしちょっと・・・
閉まってますか？
自分ではわかんないですよ、これ
蓋が閉まれれば一番いいんですけど・・・
自分じゃわかんないんですよ、閉まってるかどうかっていうのが
パコって鳴らないとダメなんすよ
暑い・・・
って感じで、こう・・・パコって隠れた状態で
彼が入って来たら
「うわっ！」って飛び出れるか？これ
あぁ、ダメだ
あんま飛び出れないぞ
どうしよう
「ばぁ！」ってなっても・・・怖いんだよ
これで、行きます
よし、じゃあ彼が来るのを待ちましょう！
あれ？ちょっと待ってよ・・・
そういうことか・・・
出れないわ・・・
あっ、ヤバい
マジで出れない
いっ・・・
ぬあぁーーーーーっ
あぁ・・・
えー？
ちょっと
あぁーーっ！腰つっ・・・つりそう、ヤバい
ちょっと待った待った待った
どうすればいい？
ちょっと待って
うあぁ・・・ヤバい！
ちょっと待った待った待った
え？マジでヤバい
どうしよう、どうしよう、どうしよう、どうしよう・・・
これしか無いな
これで出よう
ヤバい！
出れない！
オラッ、あぁっ！
あっ、あ、つりそう、足
あぁっ、ちょっと待って・・・
助けて、ほんと助けて、ちょっと待って待って待って・・・
あぁ、ヤバい！出れない、ほんと出れない
ちょっと待って待って待った
ヤバいぞ！
こんな所で死ぬわけにはいかん
うわぁ～～～っ！
ちょっと・・・！
なんで出れないよ、ちょっと
誰か～
どうしよう・・・どうすればいいんだろう？
えぇ？ちょっと、ほんとにやばい
ああやべぇもうこれ、やべぇな
こういう感じの人になっちゃう
ドッキリはよくなったよ
今日の動画は、バケツにハマったときに出る方法です
どうしようとりあえずエアコン付けたい
めっちゃ暑いんだわこれ
振ってもでれないんだよ
あ〜
焼きそば食いたい
あーーーー
うわ～～
これネタと思ってるでしょ
ガチなんすよ
ネタでこんな変なことしねーよ
ドッキリするつもりだったし
やばいどうしようほんとにどうしよう
なんか物に掴んで倒れれば一番いいんですけど
物まで引き寄せれない
あ〜
ちょっとまってどうしよう
まってほんとにやばい
どうしどうすればいい
足が完全にハマってんだよもう
待って待ってほんとにやばい
腰痛くなってきた
あーちょっとやばいやばいっ
何かに掴んで倒れよう
それしかない
よっしゃ
よし
これで倒れたら出れるでしょ
あー痛ー
あーやばい
あーやばい腰いてぇんだよこれ
あ、待って待って出れなくなんじゃん
ちょっとまって
やばいやばい足やばいちょっと待った
よし、これで倒れればいける
こんな出方しかできないのか
いやいやいやいやいやいやいや
うわーーーーーーーーーー
あーーー